el valor del límite cuando x tiende a 0
de 1 / x al cubo por la integral de 0 a
x de t por el logaritmo natural de 1 más
te entre t a la 44 dt es entonces
tenemos que calcular este límite
la primera quizás esta intención podría
ser resolver esta integral verdad pero
pues no sé quizás esto nos sugiere
utilizar un arco tangente pero tenemos
un logaritmo natural estorbando quizás
resolverlo por partes o quizás por
sustitución trigonométricas quién sabe a
esto parece que va a ser imposible o
quizás muy complicado muy difícil de
realizar pero pues en realidad no se
trata de resolver la integral sino de
calcular el límite entonces vamos a
utilizar este hecho que queremos
calcular el límite para ver que no es
necesario calcular este integral muy
bien y lo voy a reescribir de esta forma
para que se vea más claro a dónde quiero
llegar entonces tenemos el límite cuando
x tiende a cero y voy a poner la
integral en un denominen un numerador
perdón y va de 0 a x
por el logaritmo natural de uno más
entre t a la 44
dt y luego dividimos todo esto entre x
al cubo verdad todo esto entre x al cubo
y ahora que ya estás viendo lo hace de
esta forma quizás ya estén sonando
campanitas en tu cabeza que dicen cómo
van a poder resolver este problema si no
lo ves aún vamos a explorar lo tenemos
digamos qué pasa con el límite de arriba
el límite de arriba nos dice el límite
cuando x se aproxima a 0 de la integral
de 0 a x
dt por el logaritmo natural de uno más
entre t a la 4 que a la 44
dt y esto por supuesto pues si vamos
calculando la integral de 0 a x y luego
x se va aproximando a 0 pues esto será
igual a la integral de 0 a 0 de esto
mismo verdad es lo mismo de ahí dt y
esto pues la integral de 0 a 0 es el
área bajo la curva de esta función la
gráfica de esta función en un punto pues
ahí no hay no hay
no hay área verdad entonces esto es ser
muy bien ahora qué pasa si dividimos
entre el límite de la otra función
tenemos el límite cuando x tiende a 0 de
x al cubo y esto por supuesto es muy
fácil de ver que es 0 verdad entonces
aquí ya está gritando qué es lo que
vamos a tener que utilizar para resolver
el problema verdad porque tenemos una
forma indeterminada que es 0 entre 0 así
que ahorita ya está sonando y gritando
en tu cabeza un resultado matemático que
ha de estar diciendo úsame úsame verdad
y ese se llama la regla del hopital la
regla regla de l'hospital
la regla del hopital y justo nos dice la
regla del hopital cómo calcular límites
de la forma 0 entre 0 muy bien y
simplemente es derivar arriba y derivar
abajo entonces si derivamos vamos vamos
a ir escribiendo esto esto es el límite
cuando x tiende a cero de quién vamos a
calcular la derivada de abajo eso es muy
fácil y esto es 3x cuadrada 3x cuadrada
ahora qué pasa si calculamos la derivada
de lo de arriba la derivada de lo de
arriba pues hay que acordarnos
justamente de este otro teorema que es
el teorema fundamental del cálculo del
cálculo perdón que nos dice que si
derivamos respecto de x la integral de a
x de una función con respecto de t
entonces esto simplemente es evaluar la
función en x es es cancelar la derivada
y evaluarla en x verdad entonces si
derivamos esta integral simplemente será
estoy adentro evaluado en x entonces
tenemos tenemos
x logaritmo natural de 1 t sobre x a la
44 verdad y ahora podríamos intentar
resolver esto y si nos damos cuenta lo
de abajo de tiende a cero verdad cuando
x tiende a cero esto tiende a cero y lo
de arriba cuando x tiende a cero bueno
esto se hace cero y aquí cuatro sin
embargo acá tenemos cero por el
logaritmo natural de uno verdad aquí no
era 3x dijimos evaluar en x
dijimos evaluar en x ahí se me falta se
me fue pero bueno si evaluamos en 0
entonces esto se vuelve 0 por el
logaritmo natural de 1 verdad porque
hice 0 y esto es 0 y volvemos a tener
una forma aplicable de la regla del
hopital pero derivar y esto sería muy
complicado así que lo más sencillo es
manipular esto algebraica mente y ver si
se puede simplificar vamos a ver
esto será el límite cuando x tiende a 0
de quien bueno pues esto es x logaritmo
natural de 1 x entre 3 x cuadrada verdad
x x a la 44 muy bien esto ya sea que lo
hagas por la regla del sandwich o
simplemente viendo que un número que
está dividiendo dividido lo volvemos a
dividir pues es simplemente de esta
forma y esto ahora si abajo tiende a
cero verdad porque es 3 por 0 por 4
verdad y si x vale 0 que es 0 y lo de
arriba también vale cero cuando x tiende
a cero entonces podemos ahora si otra
vez utilizar la regla del hopital porque
esto se ve de la forma 0 entre 0
entonces y derivamos arriba lo que nos
queda es lo siguiente
es el límite cuando x tiende a 0 y
arriba tenemos
antes que nada podríamos cancelar esto
verdad se podemos cancelar esta x con
una de estas equis y es mucho más
sencillo ahora la derivada del logaritmo
es 1 entre 1 x muy bien y ahora lo de
abajo pues tenemos que utilizar pues la
regla del producto ahora sería la
derivada de este primero que es 3 que
multiplica a este otro x a la 4 + 4
13 x por la derivada del segundo por la
derivada del segundo es 4 x al cubo y
ahora cuando esto lo hacemos tender a
cero pues nos damos cuenta que el de
arriba tiende a uno tiende a 1 y el de
abajo que tiende esto es 3 por 0 más
bueno 3 por 4 verdad porque x vale 0
entonces esto es 12 y aquí es 3 x 0 x 0
es más 0 verdad entonces esto
simplemente fue un doceavo que 'quien
presión impresionante queríamos calcular
el límite de una integral y resulta que
no tuvimos ni siquiera que calcular la
integral ya acabamos esta expresión
complicada parecía que que teníamos que
calcular la integral pero no nos
libramos de eso y qué suerte que
contamos con con la regla del hospital y
el teorema fundamental del cálculo para
poder resolver este problema sin
operaciones complicadas